ce
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
à mes toiles à commencer par une
question selon vous quel est le lien
entre la multiculturalité et une barre
chocolatée comme celle que j'ai en main
je vous la corde c'est pas évident que
c'est là que l'histoire d'emma histoire
qui m'a amené ici ce soir devant vous
depuis tout petit j'ai eu la chance de
voyager découvrir des paysages des
personnes et de tomber amoureux de
l'étranger étrangers au sens large au
sens général du terme
et cet amour m'a conduit à lyon
imaginez-vous deux ans plus tôt avec moi
à lyon une ville que je découvre et que
j'ai rejoint pour un master
d'entreprenariat internationale découvre
donc lyon à vivre aimer nouveaux
camarades de classe vingt-huit personnes
de 12 pays différents de la chine
passant par à la colombie l'indonésie un
suisse nicaragua et l'inde
vous connaissez l'âme ce pays immense on
mange et pis c'est tout le temps même au
petit déj
le découvert par la suite nous voici à
lyon à faire connaissance et un des
premiers jours un des mes nouveaux
camarades
un des premiers jours sans dans la
cuisine commune et l'heure du goûter est
arrivé je prends donc ma fameuse barre
chocolatée que jour je commence à manger
un croc de rock et la dame et nouveaux
camarades village en re sur la photo
s'approche de moi regarde la barre
chocolatée
il la prend dans les mains prend aux
crocs
il me la rend il s'en va
comme si de rien était tout va bien et
donc là ceux qui me connaissent savent
que j'avais qu'une seconde très
difficile de ma vie la nourriture et moi
c'est une histoire passionnée et c'est
peu de le dire
et donc je me suis dit héros est-ce que
tu l'assassinent ou est-ce que tu prends
conscience que quelque chose de
potentiellement extraordinaire
bouleversement de bon sens du terme est
en train de se passer en je vous rassure
j'ai pris la seconde option et à partir
de là les douze mois qui ont suivi
quatre mois en france à lyon 4 - chine
un retour de shanghai et quatre aux usa
avwest lafayette près de chicago avec
ses 28 personnes de 7 12 pays différents
24 sur 24 7 jours sur 7 ont été
extraordinaires fenomeno magique
j'ai appris qu'en inde la nourriture se
partage avec tout le monde tout le temps
donc virage qui s'approche de moi qui
prends ma part chocolatées c'est normal
tout comme derrière moi qu'ils pouvaient
aller dans son plat goûter ce que je
n'ai fait que très rarement j'ai appris
à manger du poisson avec des baguettes
imaginez moi j'ai un groupe jeune
poisson avec des baguettes
franchement c'est pas facile la chine
est un pays que peu de nous connaissions
qui vraiment sublime qui regorge de
paysages magnifiques de gens vraiment
vraiment sympathique et donc après ces
douze mois avec toutes ces personnes
j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai beaucoup
grandi j'ai beaucoup mûri nous sommes
nourris les uns des autres et j'ai
compris qu'en fait plus que l'amour de
l'étranger c'est l'amour de la
multiculturalité qui m'anime je me mets
ici devant vous aujourd'hui et que je
partage avec vous ce concept
la multiculturalité ce moment est très
important
le philosophe spinoza défend l'idée
qu'il n'ya dans nature rien de plus
important pour un homme
que notre homme animé par la raison
alors sa part des débats philosophiques
très complexe très con ça pose ensemble
sur ce point pris mais le prix mondial
du discours il n'ya dans la nature rien
de plus important pour une personne vaut
par exemple madame précision pour un
groupe de personnes qu'une autre
personne animé par la raison
cela est vrai depuis la nuit des temps
que c'était pour la cueillette des
fruits dans les arbres pour la conquête
des plus grands empires
nous sommes rassemblés pour avancer
ensemble cependant dans d'autres
évolutions me crée des barrières entre
nous des barrières de nos différentes
couleurs de peau différents langages aux
différentes croyances différentes
géographie ni barrière invisible mais
bien réel
on a vécu françois dans ce bus avec d'un
côté les antillais de l'autre les
japonais je crois réellement que cette
barre chocolatée et ce qu'elle
représente dans une réponse facile à
notre portée est évidente
pourquoi avez-vous dit en trois raisons
la première c'est la simple et plus en
curiosité le proverbe qui dit la
curiosité est un vilain défaut et à
mettre à la poubelle ou en tout cas à
prendre de très grandes pincettes
albert einstein aurait dit je ne suis
pas très intelligent j'ai juste
extrêmement curieux on ne sait pas si
c'est 100% véridique et ça allait il est
aussi très modeste ça montre bien ce
point fort la curiosité est à l'origine
de toutes les plus grandes découvertes
nature de l'humanité ait perdu des temps
être multiculturelle
c'est avant tout être curieux tout
simplement deuxièmement mieux se
connaître soi même quand vous
rencontrerez les gens seraient amenés à
poser des questions demandait d'où
viens-tu et combien d'habitants qu'est
ce qu'on mange chez toi et ces gens
posant des questions en retour en grâce
à voir aller beaucoup plus loin à savoir
raconter il réellement qui vous êtes
vous venez pour toutes les complexités
historique géographique culturel imaginé
raconté un chinois la campagne chinoise
la martinique
cette île de la caraïbe habite autres
par des amérindiens colonisée par les
français les anglais des français les
anglais ainsi de suite devenu
département puis région territoire
européen situé à 1 osterloh distance de
l'europe avec des gens quand même le
coloré une nourriture différentes
tout comme cette barre chocolatée
merci